اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي في وقت سابق اعتراض
صواريخ اطلقت من جنوب لبنان واعتبرت غير
مسبوقه وذلك منذ حرب 2006 من جانبه تعهد
وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي باتخاذ جميع
الاجراءات لحمايه امن بلاده فيما اعلن
لبنان فتح تحقيق بالتعاون مع اليونيفير
لمعرفه الجهه المسؤوله عن اطلاق الصواريخ
الجيش اللبناني اعلنا العثور على منصتين
اطلقت منهما صواريخ فيما لم يتضح بعد من
يقف وراء هذا الهجوم قناه 12 الاسرائيليه
قالت ان التقييم الامني يشير الى وقوف
فصائل فلسطينيه وراء اطلاق الصواريخ فيما
نفى مصدر مقرب من حزب الله اي علاقه للحزب
باطلاق الصواريخ مؤكدا الروايه
الاسرائيليه بان فصائل فلسطينيه وراء
الاطلاق
[موسيقى]
جماعه عم يطلع الصواريخ من عنا شايفين
شايفين من وين
لكم من وين عم يطلع الصواريخ
[موسيقى]